we're going to begin with its president
Trump's impeachment trial will put a
spotlight on another powerful government
figure the Chief Justice of the United
States John Roberts he was sworn in
yesterday to preside over the Senate
trial this is only the third time in
history a Chief Justice has performed
that role how he navigates this
political and partisan fight could have
a profound impact on Americans view of
the federal courts Jan Crawford is
outside the Supreme Court Jan good
morning he already had a hard job now
he's got an even harder job it would
seem how is he going to handle it all
well you know he's still going to be
performing his duties here at the
Supreme Court but for the next few weeks
it's going to be leaving the
collegiality of this place and go across
the street to preside over a very
different very partisan trial and many
have speculated that that has got to be
his worst nightmare but people who know
him best say he's also going to see it
as an opportunity to show the
independence of the federal judiciary so
help you God I do with that John G
Roberts was sworn in yesterday to take
on a role outlined in the Constitution
when the President of the United States
has tried the Chief Justice shall
preside but unlike most trials where
judges are in complete control here
it'll be the Senate that has the first
and last word Jeff Rossen president and
CEO of the National Constitution Center
says Roberts his role is to be a symbol
of neutrality to be accepted by both
sides as fair as not favoring one side
or another sitting at the center of a
political fight poses a unique challenge
for the 64 year old chief justice he's
no fan of the limelight and going back
to his 2005 confirmation hearings has
fiercely defended the independence of
federal judges comparing them to umpires
who call balls and strikes the role of
an umpire and a judge is critical they
make sure everybody plays by the rules
but in an impeachment trial not only
does the Senate set the rules it can by
a majority vote overturn any of
Roberts's rulings
the Senate will convene as a court of
impeachment 21 years ago Roberts's
predecessor the late Chief Justice
William Rehnquist presided over
President Clinton's impeachment trial I
do but he only made one ruling that
senators were more than jurors because
the Senate could also dictate the trial
like a judge it's all the more important
to have a figure who is recognized by
both sides as above politics and that's
why it's so important that it's Chief
Justice Roberts Chief Justice has been
quick to defend federal judges from
partisan attacks including by President
Trump we do not serve one party or one
interest we serve one nation that's one
reason why Harvard law schools Richard
Lazarus Roberts his longtime friend says
the chief may see the trial as an
opportunity to show the American people
the nonpartisan nature of the way the
judges and justices work he said Roberts
will not shy away from making a ruling
even if it could be overridden he's not
just going to be an incentive player
because the fact is he wants to show the
American people the face of the Supreme
Court now while Roberts will be
presiding over that trial the Supreme
Court also is going to be taking up some
of the most contentious issues of our
time from gay rights abortion gun rights
the dreamers immigration program even
president Trump's tax returns all of
these cases even more likely to make
Roberts try to remain above the fray
Anthony all right Jan thank you in the
trial of course in the Senate begins
next Tuesday